[Applause]
i want to find
aliens finding life on another planet is
not just going to be a little hard
it's going to be very hard but for the
first time in human history
we have a chance to detect signs of life
on another planet
or maybe we've already detected it on
venus
or maybe not there are still two big
hurdles when it comes to confirming life
on another world
the first is building a telescope big
enough to do this
and the second is interpreting what
we'll find when we think of
extraterrestrial life we tend to think
of aliens
like funny little green men not aliens
as single-celled microbes but it's
actually detecting signs of microbial
life on another planet
that i'm most optimistic about and what
i focus my research on
i model how a star's high energy
radiation can make gases for microbes
harder
or easier to see with future telescopes
microbes have dominated our planet's
biosphere for most of earth's history
they've been emitting gases that can be
seen in our atmosphere
even light years away for billions of
years now if an
alien astronomer were looking at earth
they would probably detect gases like
oxygen
methane and nitrous oxide before
detecting signs of us
even with an active biosphere like
earth's most of the gases that indicate
life
are coming from single-celled microbes
not from animals
this is what we'll try to do in the next
decade of astronomy
try to find signs of microbial life on
planets orbiting other stars
but the technology to detect the
atmosphere of a planet the size of earth
around another sun is incredibly
difficult it's like trying to determine
the size of a firefly
in front of a spotlight while looking
from another continent
what's amazing is that with telescopes
in the 2020s
we're overcoming this technological
barrier the second issue to finding
alien life will be to interpret what
these biosignature gases actually mean
21 of our atmosphere is oxygen and
nearly all of that oxygen comes from
life
so here's the tricky question would
detecting oxygen
on another planet mean life no
not necessarily because we know of ways
to get oxygen without biology
i try to understand a planet's geology
and it stars radiation so that we can
better identify a true life signal
and this is what makes the preliminary
detection on venus of phosphine
a potential biosignature gas so
compelling
but also so confusing venus is not where
we expected to find life
it is a hellish world with a surface
temperature of nearly 900 degrees
fahrenheit
could life be floating in the more
temperate upper atmosphere
but then how would such life eat and
reproduce this discovery will have to be
vetted over the coming decade
first we must verify the detection of
phosphine itself
and then later we would have to confirm
that this gas is coming from life
and not from some unexpected geological
or photochemical process
if true this would be one of the most
profound discoveries of our generation
if it turns out that we were fooled that
we mistook this gas for biology when
it's from some other process
we will have a sobering lesson to apply
to planets orbiting distant stars
venus is close literally our next door
neighbor
and yet we still have trouble
understanding it the planets we're
finding
orbiting other stars are weird and
unexpected
some have the density of cotton candy
and others
rain molten iron and most stars are
different from our sun
with high energy flares that can make it
difficult for life
so the more we're looking at different
biosignature gases
the more we realize that there's no
single gas that's enough to understand a
planet
and to claim alien life it is just
really difficult to distinguish life
from non-life from light years away and
here's where the ambiguity lies
how will we know if a clue is a sign of
life or is not
well first we'll need to understand as
much as we can about aquinas geology
and the star at orbits we'll learn vital
lessons by exploring our own solar
system
in places such as venus and mars we are
getting closer to answering one of
humanity's biggest questions
are we alone in the universe
any claim will be hotly debated so
basically i'm stretched between two
desires
i want to find alien life but likely
will not have a clear answer
and that's okay science is nuanced and
self-correcting
it's what i love about it science is
about balancing this duality
of skepticism and of hope we won't be
able to teleport ourselves to another
planet
and take pictures of alien kangaroos
jumping around
and without an intelligent hello
earthling signal we might still feel
lonely
even if we find out we're not alone in
the universe
despite these challenges i'm super
excited about alien microbes and what
they could teach us
even if we find just one other sign of
life then likely the universe is teeming
with it
from single-celled to complex if we
search for decades and find nothing
then that is equally humbling but we
must try
we must do this search even when it
means sitting with uncertainty
along the way thank you
you